i'm excited to hear all the speakers and
learn about their perspective on the
topic that is dear to me i've been a
student of bioinformatics
all of my life so i'm excited that i'm
working with many of you here today on
making this discipline more accessible
it is also great to see as much as
broader rpc appreciation of data in the
life science domain as well as great
excitement about the potential impact of
bioinformatics on areas touching the
lives of everyone such as medicine
vaccine design genomic surveillance and
even space travel
so let me take this opportunity to
briefly introduce myself our team
since 20 2019 we have launched the omics
logic in india with initial
collaborations at several universities
where we piloted our training worked
with faculty to develop programs that
addresses the major gap in
bioinformatics education
so uh we saw that with the evident
evident of many uh breakthroughs in
molecular biology advances of
advancements in precision medicine uh
biotechnology and agriculture new
technologies were adopted in the
industry and research that
research that simplifies generation of
accurate and in-depth data
however a lack of analytical power
and a lack of analytic analytical power
and appropriate skills amongst
researchers and students
researchers and students created a huge
gap between data and information that is
needed in this field
so
the technical demand prevents that for
happening so uh
and that that limitation that limiting
ability to rely on techniques such as
rna sequencing genomic sequencing but
after working with many students at
universities in india we discovered even
more interesting insights that were
relevant today
so after many programs coordinating with
universities and thousands of students
across india we saw that there is a gap
in the skills that help students
effectively integrate
these studies into their research
projects thinking critically about data
and applying appropriate analysis
methods to the right data
so in most of these case studies in on
in most of these cases that meant
students were able uh were able to learn
develop independent research project in
a short period of time and get excited
about the opportunity and apply
bioinformatics in domains like oncology
neuroscience infectious diseases and
agriculture
so this overwhelming majority of
students were surveyed
pointed
to their interest to recommend such
trainings and integrate them into their
curriculum
and this is why i think all of this
makes sense and this is why we are here
today to discuss what can our education
system do about this gap how do schools
colleges and universities prepare
students for the future of biotechnology
life sciences in general where bio
biology is acquiring the characteristics
of data science so how we manage to do
this and how we are going to overcome
this is very important so this symposium
is extremely important for us and hope
you all are excited as we are to hear
about these challenges not from just us
from our team but from experts who have
spent their entire life struggling to
learn about these challenges and more
importantly come up with great solutions
so to tell you more about the symposium
so in the next two days we will hear
these speakers address these topics we
can all relate to so how to stand out
from a crowd when you apply for an
academic program or a career in
bioinformatics
what can universities
do to equip their students with relevant
skills and experiences
what is the future of this field where
will you find cutting-edge
challenges that you can contribute to
so we separated these topics into two
days uh the first day is about the
challenging role of bioinformatics in
research industry and education and the
second day is on how you can get
involved and make an impact
finally after the speakers present their
insights to us uh in the form of short
20 minute long presentations we will
have a chance to ask them about the
prospective on the future of
bioinformatics in india and if you have
any questions and i'm asking all of you
here
to ask your questions that you would
want to get answers
ahead of the
ahead and you can go ahead with the
symposium page and submit your questions
there as well as well as you can put
them in the chat i will ask our support
team to monitor our submissions and
prepare them for the panel discussion so
the panel discussion will start at 4 45
pm uh ist so that would be
almost 50 minutes from now after we have
the sessions uh from the mentors